قال مراقب الدوله الاسرائيلي نتنياهو
انجلمان انه سيجري التحقيق في المسؤوليه
عن احداث السابع من اكتوبر الماضي على كل
المستويات سياسيا وعسكريا ومدنيا ونقل
موقع والا الاخباري عن انجلمان قوله ان
الاف
الاسرائيليين تركوا لمصائر يوم السابع من
اكتوبر بينما تحولت مئات الالاف من السكان
تحول تحولوا على خطي المواجهه في شمال
وجنوب اسرائيل الى معوزين وتضرر من نقص
الرعايه
الحكوميه وينضم الان الينا من القدس
الدكتور محمد هلسه الاكاديمي والخبير في
الشان الاسرائيلي دكتور محمد اهلا وسهلا
بك يعني اسرائيل اصدرت قرار
وعتمته عن الاسرى من القطاع ا او الوضع في
القطاع بشكل العام ولكن هذا النوع من
الاخبار
يعني الحديث عن تحقيقات
والمسؤوليه ومن يتحمل المسؤوليه
كيف يتاثر الشارع الاسرائيلي بسماع هذه
الاخبار الى جانب اخبار الجنود المصابين
والذين يعني يصابون بكوابيس ويطلقون النار
بطريقه
عشوائيه الشارع الاسرائيلي اصلا مصاب
بالارباع وتسود حاله من الاحباط والغضب
وربما ينفس غضبه من خلال ما يكتب ان على
مستوى المواقع التواصل الاجتماعي او ما
يكتبه المفكرون والسياسيون وما تكتبه
الصحف المختلفه اي عن هذه ان ان مشهد
الارباك هذا الحديث عن التحقيق يجري في
اطار محاوله طمانه الجمهور الاسرائيلي بان
هنالك مؤسسات ناظمه وتعمل وفق القانون
الاسرائيلي لكن جزء كبير جدا من المجتمع
الاسرائيلي يدرك بان مراقب الدوله الذي
يتبع لكنيسته الاحتلال ليس لديه صلاحيات
وهو قادر فقط على توصيف وتشخيص الحاله
العامه ربما يشير الى بعض المسؤوليات لكنه
في نهايه المطاف يقدم تقاريره الى كنيسته
الاحتلال و ولا يملك صلاحيات ايه تنفيذيه
وبالتالي ال المشهد في داخل المجتمع
الاسرائيلي لا يردع اقصد في مستوى القياده
السياسيه والعسكريه لا يردع مثل هذه
الاخبار التي ترد لانه يعلم بانه لا انياب
ولا مخالب لهذا الجسم قادره على ان تضبط
ايقاع هذا المشهد الذي تسوده حاله من
الشعبويه تفضلتي بالاشاره الى جانتس
وخطابه جانتس يخرج من لقاء مع نتنياهو
وبينغ فير ويريد ان يظهر بمظهر البطل الذي
اثر البقاء في داخل الحكومه رغم خلافه مع
بينغ فير على قضيه اقصاء مفوضه السجون رغم
الاتفاق المسبق بان تبقى في مرحله الحرب و
يبقى كبار القاده الامنيين فيها وهو يعني
هذا خطاب اعلاني
دعائي شعبوي يخاطب فيه جزء كبير جدا من
الاسرائيليين وهو يعلم بانه بقاه يعود
عليه بالمنفعه في داخل الحكومه لانه رصيده
لدى الناخبين الاسرائيليين هو يبحث في
النهايه عن مصلحته السياسيه هو يريد يعني
الكرسي وهذا ربما ما المح اليه الكل
عندما دخل في هذه الحرب بهذه الطريقه ولكن
في النهايه هناك نتنياهو الذي يواجه من
جهه يعني تهم بالفساد وهناك محكمه في
فبراير القادم يعني ليس ببعيد وايضا الان
هذا التحقيق بالمسؤوليه
والفشل الى اي حد نتوقع ان يعني التوقيت
الان يمكن ان يؤثر على وضعه سواء سياسيا
او او في
الميدان ال ال المشكله امام المجتمع
الاسرائيلي ان
نتنياهو يشعر بان هنالك هامش وهامش كبير
جدا اي يتاح له في بسبب الثقافه السياسيه
السائده في د في داخل المجتمع الاسرائيلي
التي لا تلزمه في هذه المرحله ولا تضغط
عليه في هذه المرحله ليقف عند هذه النقطه
وا لا يجد في داخل المجتمع الاسرائيلي في
داخل الشارع الاسرائيلي حراك ضاغط يلزمه
بان يفعل ما يفعله حتى مع صدور هذه
الاخبار عن تحقيقات من مراقب الدوله حتى
مع الانتقادات الكبيره التي توجه لنتنياهو
حتى مع ضغط ايزنكوت وجانتس لمحاوله الدخول
الى المرحله الثالثه او الاعلان عن البدء
بالمرحله الثالثه وهذا ما يتجنب نتنياهو
لانه يعلم بان الدخول الى المرحله الثالثه
يعني ان يلتزم بسقف زمني وهو لا يريد ان
يلتزم بسقف زمني يريد ان يبقي المشهد
مفتوحا لمحاوله الهروب قدر الامكان الى
الامام وهو مستمر في هذا الامر وربما ايضا
يعني حينما يخرج جنتس الذي يعتبر الاكثر
عقلانيه في مجلس الحرب و يستمر في طرح اي
ذات السقوف التي يطرحها نتنياهو بان الحرب
مستمره هذا في اطار ان كل طرف يحاول ان
يرفع سقف شعاراته و سقف دعواته في مجتمع
ما زال لغايه هذه اللحظه مع كل هذه
الفجوات التي تجري بين التوقعات وبين
الواقع لانه ما زال هذا المجتمع يمنح
الشرعيه خلينا نحكي بنسبه عاليه جدا ولا
يضغط لوقف ه هذه الحرب لا يضغط سياسيا رغم
تشكل تيار خ ننظر لمن لمن يحاول ان يضغط
على الاقل وربما هذه مفارقه دكتور محمد
يعني كلنا نتذكر موقف ماكرون في بدايه
الحرب الان الرئاسه الفرنسيه في الواقع
تطالب
نتنياهو
نقلت الانباء ان هناك مكالمه هاتفيه اجرا
ماكرون مع نتنياهو اليوم قبل قليل وطالبه
فيها
بوقف اطلاق النار بشكل دائم ما تعليقك على
هذا النوع من
المطالب ولو سمحت قبل ان تجيب فقط اريد ان
انوه بهذا الخبر نقلا عن يدعوت احرنوت
اسرائيل تنتظر خلال الايام القليله
المقبله رد حماس عبر الوسطاء القطريين
بشان صفقه الرهائن
اذا هذه ايضا نقطه جديره بالتوقف عندها
ولكن لو سمحت تفضل علق بالنسبه للموقف
الفرنسي الغرب ذاته وماكرون ذاته هو الذي
وضع اسرائيل فوق القانون هو الذي وضع
اسرائيل في حاله الاستعلاء والغرور التي
تعيشها والتي تدير من خلالها ظهرها لكل
المجتمع الدولي والمنظومه الدوليه اسرائيل
تستظل في ظل الولايات المتحده في ظل
الموقف الامريكي وهذه التغطيه الامريكيه
التي ما زالت رغم ظهور بعض المواقف الشكل
من الولايات المتحده ما زال بامكان
اسرائيل ان تستظل في ظلها وان تمضي في
ظلها كل الذي يجري من المجتمع الغربي هذا
مجتمع منافق واعتدنا على مواقفه وو اراد
المجتمع الغربي لما جار الولايات المتحده
ولما جار اسرائيل في تبني روايتها واطلاق
يدها انت تذكرين الشعارات الكبيره التي
اطلقها ماكرون وكل القيادات الغربيه حينما
تقاطرت الى اسرائيل ورفعت عنوان عريض
استخدمته اسرائيل حتى هذه اللحظه لاسرائيل
الحق في الدفاع عن نفسها وبالتالي اسرائيل
ترى انه ب هذه المواقف التي تبدر عن
قيادات غربيه هي مواقف شكليه لم ترقى الى
مستوى ان تشكل ضاغط فعلي على الحكومه
الاسرائيليه لترد عها او تمنعها من
الاستمرار والمضيف وماذا بشان جهود
الوسطاء وايضا اضيف الى ما قلته قبل قليل
نقلا عن يدعوت احرونوت ان هناك تشاؤم في
اسرائيل بشان الحصول على رد ايجابي
والتقيييم ان الامر سيتطلب ضغطا
عسكريا اسرائيل تريد من هذا الذي تطر وهي
تفاوض بالمناسبه نفسها في هذا الامر تريد
ان تجتزئ وان تاخذ جزئيات تناسب رغباتها
وتناسب احتياجاتها هي لا تريد ان تربط
مسار التفاوض حول الاسرى وصفقه الاسرى
بمسار الحرب الذي يجري و ما زالت الدعوات
في داخل المجتمع الاسرائيلي من كبنه الحرب
ومن نتنياهو شخصيا بان هذه الحرب البريه
تاتي لاستعاده الاسرى وبالتالي جزء مما
يقال الان في المجتمع الاسرائيلي هو صدع
لصوت اسرائيل ليس اكثر اسرائيل تقول
وبالمناسبه كل الذي يجري هو مجرد اخبار
تاتي من وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه هذا هدفه
محاوله التنفيذ عن الداخل الاسرائيلي
واهام المجتمع الاسرائيلي وتحديدا عوائل
الاسرى بان هنالك جهد يبذل في مسار سياسي
معين لاستعاده هؤلاء وربما ايضا لمحاوله
استرضاء الوسطاء الدوليين وعلى راس
الولايات المتحده التي تضغط لمحاوله رؤيه
يعني متنفس او ربما نافذه امل تفتح في هذا
المسار نتنياهو يدرك بان المقاومه عند
موقفها ولم يحدث ان تراجعت ولم يحدث ان
قالت بانها ستعود عن اشتراطاتها فيما
يتعلق بضروره وقف الحرب حتى يذهب الجميع
الى مسار تفاوضي يفضي الى اتفاقات معينه
في هذا اشكرك دكتور محمد هلاس الاكاديمي
والخبير في الشان الاسرائيلي من القدس
شكرا